all right like can really said my name
is Susan Simpkins and I want to talk to
you today about getting started and what
web development specifically with how
you can start to find your first job in
front-end web development so I want to
start off by talking about Who I am just
so you know where my experience is where
I come from because depending on who you
talk to everyone works in a different
environment on different teams they look
for different things different
experience so what you hear from people
is going to be a little bit different
depending on their specialties I do
mainly front-end development and I've
also done quite a bit of UX work
specifically consulting for redesigning
websites I've been in the field for
about seven years since 2012 and
currently I'm a web designer 3 is my
official title at Oracle it's basically
a senior web designer entry levels one
then kind of like mid levels 2 and
seniors 3 it's a very corporate II title
but mainly I do front-end development I
help kind of consult on redesigns I
helped set coding standards for the team
help recommend what we need to look for
in new hires and things like that in
previously I've been a senior UX
developer at big wing it was a marketing
digital agency that's part of the
Oklahoman so it was typical agency type
work is very fast-paced a lot of small
to medium sized websites I did a lot of
UX consulting for them
information architecture user research
things like that and because we had a
very small web team I also did the
front-end development and worked with we
did mainly WordPress themes so working
with WordPress developers - they did the
backend I did the front-end so making
sure the themes were set up right the
templates were set up right things like
that before that I was a friend and
developer it I themes if you're not
familiar with them they do WordPress
plug-in development so I helped with
and then also did WordPress training so
teaching people how to get started in
using WordPress is a content content
management system mainly from a user
perspective and less of a developer's
perspective so business owners who
wanted to get in and learn how to use a
wordpress to manage their site and my
first kind of full-time job that wasn't
freelance was is a web design instructor
for a company called plural site they
acquired a company I worked in called
digital tutors and they did 3d design
and animation training there kind of tag
line was we teach people how to make
movies and games and I was brought on is
their first hire to kind of help them
get into web design tutorials it was all
front-end teaching people how to
transition from being more of a designer
to getting into coding so learning HTML
CSS where they need to get started and
things of that nature and then before
that I did freelance web design and
development for a couple years mainly
just small sites whatever I could find
I'm creating a custom design and turning
that into WordPress themes so one of the
biggest questions I get from people is
what do I need to get a job and there
are really three different things you
need to get a first job in any career
and that would especially web
development or coding you need the
technical skills you need the soft
skills to be able to work on a team
unless you're gonna be working by
yourself I can't really think of a job
where you don't at least need to work
with a client or something like that
even if you're in freelance and you're
not working on a team then you're still
gonna need those soft skills and then
also every job you're gonna find
unfortunately or not unfortunately I
guess they want experience a lot of them
kind of have unrealistic expectations
for experience because how can you get
experience before you get a first job so
we'll talk about that as well
so obviously with the technical skills
one of the biggest questions people have
is what should I learn and this is a
really hard one because there are so
many different types of development jobs
out there there are so many libraries
are so many framework
lots of different languages so anything
you can do front end you can do back in
you could be a full-stack developer you
could do DevOps you could focus on UX
development like I did for a while which
is a lot of in terms of coding a lot of
prototyping and using those to create
user tests UI development even whether
you work on applications or websites the
type of development and the skills you
need are gonna be much different so I'd
encourage you to find what you like try
out different things and try to focus on
just one or two areas because it's so
easy to get overwhelmed when you're
getting started there's so much out
there to learn that it can feel like
it's impossible to really get the skills
you need to start a job so from my
perspective which is front-end web
development I really recommend that you
start with kind of the basics learn the
basics of HTML and CSS
you might hear the buzzword html5 they
call it a version of html5 you HTML even
though it's not a version it's just
referring to you know the newer tags
although they're not really that new
anymore I think of like the semantic
elements I want someone who knows how to
use HTML elements correctly like a lot
of times you'll see code that's very
Devon tensive but there's a lot of
benefits from using more semantic
elements like the header the footer of
the section tag a side figure I mean any
of that you can think of and they have
automatic accessibility benefits when
you build websites that way so looking
for kind of knowledge into that may be a
framework like bootstrap or foundation
just to show that you can dive in and
learn one of those I don't have a
preference for either and in fact I'm
not a fan of frameworks like this in
general but so many teams will encourage
people to use them because it speeds up
development a lot but unfortunately
they're extremely bloated but it is good
to have knowledge of how to use them
because many jobs want people to be
familiar with free
works then for CSS a lot of the kind of
basic theory you like do you understand
the Cascade can you explain her
inheritance do you understand how
specificity works can you explain
different types of selectors and which
ones might override others can you
explain how or why not you might use
certain selectors in your code be able
to talk about maintainability
organization is huge a lot of people
really struggle with how to organize CSS
because it's pretty open and there's so
many different ways to do it also being
familiar with a preprocessor like sass I
think is great being able to talk about
how you set up your sass files how you
organize them your folder structure um
JavaScript a lot of my teams we haven't
been super heavy on JavaScript they've
been a lot of you know more or less
basic web sites so if you know the basic
theory of JavaScript
can you explain concepts like hoisting
for example are you familiar with a
framework it could be as simple is using
jQuery and being able to show some work
with that content management systems
WordPress is obviously my preferred
content management system because I used
to focus on WordPress theme development
and it runs over twenty five seven
percent of the web I love that it's open
source and it has the best documentation
hands-down of any content management
system out there I would bet I haven't
seen one that's better so having those
skills especially if you're gonna work
in like an agency environment like I did
or my current job I work with a lot of
marketers so all of them have to work
with a content management system on a
daily basis so you have to understand it
not only from a development perspective
but oftentimes it falls to you to kind
of be a troubleshooter and to explain to
them how to use the interface so being
able to walk people through that
version-control I've worked with a lot
of different types of version control
I prefer command line but I think the
most important part is that you know how
to use something I've worked with teams
where they only use like a GUI and
that's fine as long as you understand
the concepts behind it you know how to
back up your code preferably if you know
how to work with multiple people
accessing a repository at the same time
that's great because especially when you
run into conflicts it can be really
tricky to figure that out
and then also to kind of have a basic
idea of how we you work in a team
environment a lot of jobs I've started
at have been a new position and so they
didn't have a workflow in place so if
you don't have a process that would help
you be efficient and have a good end
product before at least a rough idea of
how you might accomplish that that then
that's really helpful because
unfortunately a lot of the times you
find out that those processes are just
not always in place and it's up to you
to create them and one other great thing
to do is to look at other people's team
processes and get an idea of their
environment and some really good things
that they recommend that you can learn
this is an example one of my former
co-workers talked about all the time 10
up is a wordpress development company
and they're engineering best practices
they thoroughly document their
philosophy what types of things they
look for they link to examples and so
I'm going through here and finding
things that you're unfamiliar with and
they talk about why it's good to know
them that can be a really good way of
kind of identifying any areas that you
need to brush up on or that you're more
interested in and things like that so
soft skills that one's really hard to
learn you can really only learn through
experiences and practicing but it's
really important to be able to
communicate to that that to someone in
an interview
as you're working on projects especially
if you're working with other people in
their code if you can write down
examples or try to remember times when
you ran into a problem and how you
communicated to overcome those problems
anything that shows that you like to
collaborate with people and a desire to
keep learning and growing so you guys
already doing great you're coming to
meetups like this and meeting people and
networking and so yeah being able to
talk about how you're active in the
community those are really good ways to
show a lot of these soft skills so how
do you learn the skills that you need
education obviously is one of the
easiest ways most people I've ever
worked with have been self-taught as
developers so it's totally fine if
you're teaching yourself or don't really
have a degree in it as long as you can
demonstrate that you have the experience
and the skills that you need for a job
so there's formal training I don't have
any experience firsthand with University
programs but from what I have heard it
can be hard for them to stay up to date
since technology changes so rapidly Tech
and vocational school I went to Francis
Tuttle's web design and development
program for two years full time I
started as web development I did that
for a year and then I did web design for
a year after that and I can't recommend
that more highly if you have the time to
put into it I mean there are online
programs and there in-person programs
and it's full-time it's like a 40-hour a
week job and I know not everyone can do
that but I think that the amount of
experience and stuff you learn in a
program like that is fantastic and it's
very inexpensive compared to attending
something like a university and then you
meet other people who are in the program
so it's a great way to network I got my
first three clients when I was doing
freelance work through the instructor
there because people would come in
contact to school they can't afford to
pay an agency but they're looking for a
student and they still want to pay you
but
and it's not gonna be like a whole lot
but you get the experience and then
still making money more money than you
would it like a part-time job or
something like that so that's good
online education there's a lot of free
places that you can go learn YouTube has
all kinds of tutorials of varying
quality Codecademy learn by doing I
think that's a great way to get in and
really learn code obviously the more you
do the better you get at it
Khan Academy is good then there are paid
subscriptions video tutorials I'm a
little bit biased here because I worked
for a plural site and I'm still doing
training here and there for them on the
side so I think that's good but I also
don't really learn well through video
training even though I create it which
is kind of ironic but like you know
there's so many different types of
education that can suit your learning
style that and you know for all kinds of
cost levels such a great field they
pretty much anyone can find a way if as
long as they have the drive and the
desire to to learn the skills and then
obviously through the community
attending meetups watching talks going
to conferences anything you can do to
kind of see what other people are
talking about it's a great way to
identify what types of things that you
need to or want to learn more about so
how do you get the experience which is
one of the hardest things because
everyone wants to see it seems like 3 to
5 years of experience when they put out
a job posting and in junior developers
what we look for is rather than 3 to 5
years of experience I mean that's
completely and realistic to ask someone
before they even have their first
position so I think if you can get any
kind of real-world experience that's
what we look for having a couple
examples of live websites like when I
got my first job I think I had three
wide live web sites up and I got those
through
the school like I talked about through
the community meeting people if you
don't find anything that way you could
always ask friends and family I mean it
seems like everyone has an idea for a
website or an app so just volunteering
even if you have to to get that
experience ask them to pay for like the
hosting and the domain and then you have
those real examples to show for a
portfolio so showing those work examples
you could do through a portfolio one
great ways to have a personal website
and then you could talk about how you
designed and built your own website as
well so they have another example of
work
LinkedIn has spots where you can upload
examples if you work there and then you
could link to live examples if you don't
have time to build a personal website
and then also live code samples are a
great way to show your actual code so
hosting code in a repository like github
or whatever if you are more into like
interaction design or front-end design
then code pen is a great way to show
your work and then it's really important
in addition to just having code samples
to be able to talk about the process and
how you got to the end product when we
conduct interviews that's something that
really stands out is that not that they
can just show the work but they can
really talk about how they got to the
end product what they did - to plan to
research to come up with the idea if
that was a part of it what kind of
development planning did you do what
kind of tools did you use why did you
use those tools those types of things
are speaking able to talk about those
can show a lot about your work and use a
person so actually finding a job and
most people I know have found jobs
through personal connections which can
be kind of intimidating when you're
getting started in a new field maybe you
don't have a lot of personal connections
but coming to stuff like this going to
user groups meeting people
is a really really great way just to
find find connections even through
previous jobs you may have had you never
know even if you started in a different
field or a different career maybe
there's a job opening on a web team
somewhere and you know somewhere in a
different department they can often
introduce you to someone who can help
you kind of get a foot in the door and
then there's always recruiters and
there's a lot of mixed opinions on
recruiters but there are good ones that
exist I've worked with some really great
ones just kind of watch out for some red
flags like if they don't listen to you
if they're often sending you jobs that
have nothing to do with what your focus
is like I get a lot of jobs for Oracle
database development which is not at all
what I do is front-end developer I think
they to see Oracle in my profile and
then to see me send it to me anyway
based on the keywords or dotnet jobs I
don't I don't know dotnet at all so pay
attention to the ones that do try to
send you jobs that match what you're
looking for and then also be firm with
what you want one time I worked with a
recruiter and he told me to straight off
he was like we're not gonna get the
salary you're asking for and I was like
well can we just submit it in I'll
interview and if it's not a fit it's not
a fit and try to argue me out of it and
I was like just do it anyway if you
don't want to work with me that's fine
I'll keep on looking somewhere else and
we went in there and then I got the job
offer I wanted to so they don't always
they aren't always exact experts on what
the requirements and possibilities of a
position are because it wasn't like it
was a unreasonable request it was like
perfectly within the market value for
that position they just yeah ask
questions and make sure that you're
getting what you deserve out of it and
there
trying to take too much of a cut out of
what you deserve for your skills and
another good thing about recruiters is
it's really great for interview practice
so if interviews make you really nervous
even if something might not be an ideal
job for you obviously you don't want to
waste someone's time but if there are
ones that you might be interested in
getting in there and just getting the
experience talking to people and
interview see how different companies
conduct interviews can be really great
so if you do find a perfect job that
comes along if you have that experience
and you can be comfortable and confident
in an interview then that'll go a long
way and job postings all over the place
obviously there's a big places like
LinkedIn Glassdoor indeed that make it
really easy do you fill out a
[Music]
application and put your resume up on
the internet I actually found my first
job in a newspaper posting in the
Oklahoman so don't you know you can find
a job anywhere even in places that you
might not expect and job descriptions
when you're looking for postings often
they're written by someone in HR someone
who doesn't have any experience with the
team or the day-to-day responsibilities
of a job so you might find all kinds of
things that have nothing to do with that
what the actual position is so if you
can get on the phone and talk to someone
or someone on the team oftentimes
something that may not initially seem
like you have the skills for would be a
good fit for you could often be a really
good job that was just kind of botched
by someone trying to do their best to
write a description of a job that they
that they don't understand and
interviews as I mentioned it's really
good to get real practice just get out
there and see what it's like also when I
was first interviewing I would research
typical interview questions for a
position and then ask my friends and
family to walk me through a mock
interview
sound silly but it made me feel a lot
better about whether someone was going
to try to trip me up with something that
I had thought through a lot of common
questions before and kind of had a
starting place that I could talk about
and adjust to any additional questions
they had or the environment or the type
of company and be prepared to talk about
your work go through your past examples
think about the type of project anyone
you've worked with the type of tools be
able to talk about your process and
explain that when you're in a natural
interview make sure you ask the
interviewers lots of questions
especially try to find out things like
what's the actual job like it can be
very hard to identify that based on the
job posting or even based on like
initial interactions with people a lot
of times I'll get in a job and it's
completely different from the impression
I was given from the initial interview
so ask about a typical project what the
deadlines are if you can walk around the
office and get a feel for the team or
the office environment especially if
you're there later in the day you can
get a feel for maybe whether there's a
good work-life balance or maybe if
people are overworked based on how they
interact with you how they look I did
one interview that I turned down because
they I got there at 2:00 p.m. and I was
interviewing until 7 p.m. including an
impromptu dinner so I had a good idea
that maybe they weren't gonna be super
respectful of work-life balance which is
really important to me so being able to
figure that out ahead of time is great
and also company culture there people do
they seem happy are they talking or is
everyone at their desk kind of silent do
they look miserable all types of things
can give you some some cues as to what
the environment is like interviews also
also have a couple typical stages
usually or at least where I've been
a part of interviews there's a either a
phone interview or an in-person
interview that's basically a screening
to kind of see does this person have the
basic skills they say they have is this
someone we could see being a good fit
for the position and then follow that
with a more detailed technical interview
so we're asking specific technical
questions about about projects about
technologies theory things like that and
then if there is a final interview or
maybe this is combined with prior
interviews questions about are they
culture fit would they be able to work
with the team well do they are they able
to collaborate collaborate collaborate
is their communication good kind of
getting those seeing if they have those
skills because at the end of the day if
someone has the technical skills if
you're not going to be able to work with
them for various reasons then they might
not be a good fit for the job
and then after interviewing kind of
deciding whether a job is a good fit for
you is really important sometimes you
can be eager to accept a job just
because it's exciting to have a job
offer but they obviously jobs can be bad
so make sure you research the company
and the team try to get a good idea of
the company's values the team values
what type of team they are also even
though a team might be great they might
not be a good fit for how you work in an
individual I've worked in an open office
environment and my team was fantastic
but I just found it really hard to focus
because they're 150 people walking
around the office every day and I I'm
like a squirrel person so I just
accidentally like even though I don't
want to just like watch people as
they're walking across the floor because
I just get distracted so for me having a
little bit more of a quiet office is a
lot better for my productivity watch out
and see if they have high turnover
obviously there's probably a reason that
people are leaving if they're leaving
ask some questions about work-life
balance if that's important to you some
companies don't really respect that
especially watch out if they want to
give you a company phone or some time I
mean everyone has a laptop these days
but you see that could be kind of a sign
that they want you to be able to work at
any time brand-new positions can be kind
of hard often if it's your first or
especially if it's your first job in a
field because when there's a brand new
position a lot of the times they don't
have a concrete idea of what your job
responsibilities are gonna be and so
that can be extra stressful in a first
job trying to figure out what this job
should be and also trying to get your
feet off the ground and get used to a
new career field so yeah a necessary
stress there sometimes but it could also
be a great opportunity if you are
willing to deal with that stress you get
to really have a lot of role in shaping
a position and the workflow and kind of
the processes for a company which can be
really cool and then outdated technology
if there are several years behind that
can be really frustrating if they're not
keeping up to date because then you as a
person you have to learn older
technology and then that can kind of
hurt your marketability or your ability
to find and grow into new positions
because you're not able to kind of learn
and stay up-to-date on the job as much
as you would be if someone was using
newer technologies and then work
environment I kind of touched on already
open offices at least for me some people
love them because they can get up and
talk and collaborate if they're on a
team where they have to have a lot of
interaction and discussions that can be
really good but I get really distracted
as mentioned working from home in my
current job I work from home probably
three to four days a week can go in for
like three four half days and then
go home for some people if you can get
kind of cagey get cabin fever if your
home all the time
but I like not having a commute and if I
want to wear my pajamas I try not to but
I can if I just feel like being
comfortable for the day and then getting
a feel for the office culture like I've
had some jobs where I'm still friends
with people I worked with six years ago
we have our own slack group and we're
great friends and it's awesome we do
game night so we have a D&D group and a
book club and that's so much fun and
then I've worked with other office
cultures where I only know a couple
people and people come and go a lot so
you don't really get to know any one
that well which is fine just kind of
deciding what you need to get out of an
office culture and making sure that your
needs are met
and that way and that's all I have so
does anyone have any questions
I think I saw yours first
that is a great question I think that
comes down to code samples so oh sorry
so the question was when you're using a
online learning platform like code
Academy how can you demonstrate their
proficiency and the skills that you
learn from a coding platform like that
and I know some of them I'm not sure I
can't remember I haven't used code
Academy in several years but some of
them do provide completion certificates
so that's something that you could list
on your resume if you're working on a
project if I remember correctly code
Academy has a lot of little mini
projects that you could do to build up
your skills you can put that on github
and you obviously want to label your
source is where you got it from we could
say I completed these code Academy
exercises and talked about the skills
you use and then they can come in and
view your code from their project so I
think that's a good way to do it
for me oh yes sir what is a typical
eight-hour workday look like for me I am
NOT a morning person and my boss knows
that we talked about it before I
accepted the job and so I start around
9:30 every day and I usually start by
checking my email I work mostly with
events marketing team and they have a
lot of urgent last-minute requests when
they're updating events and things and
so I make sure they're there's nothing
urgent that's coming in that I need to
take care of immediately and if there is
I will even I'll have coffee and go
straight in there and start pushing
updates if not then I'll go into the
office and work until 1 or 2 p.m.
because I like I get Starr crazy if I'm
home all the time but I am really
productive in my home office because I
spent some time trying to make it comfy
and in the type of environment that
makes me productive so I like a stand-up
desk and then a normal desk so if I need
to stand up I can stand up if I want to
sit down I can sit down so I finish out
the afternoon there so my days typically
from 9:30 to 5:30 every Tuesday we have
a coding team coding call and most of
the team is in the Philippines so
they're on a 13 hour time difference so
we have our call from 6:00 p.m. to 7:00
p.m. on Tuesdays yeah I can't really
think of anything else in terms of
projects okay yeah for sure that's
important mostly we work with a product
called lights EMS it was net fusion
element net fusion I think was the
company that developed it which was
acquired by NetSuite which was acquired
by Oracle and so there are a lot of
legacy websites built on light CMS so
being familiar with wordpress and other
content management systems i had to
learn how to use light CMS and build
websites and that which is kind of a
challenge because there was a lot of
technical documentation for developers
there's more for users so it's kind of
dig in and try to figure it out so I
helped with a lot of conference websites
so they're not huge websites they're
probably like 5 to 10 pages just doing
the front-end for that I help kind of
set coding standards for the team in
Manila so recently I've been doing some
recommendations for changes to projects
how they could set up projects use for
example gulp to automate tasks instead
of doing things manually how to organize
an optimizer CSS based on common
engineering best practices and were
migrating a website over unto Oracle's
content management system while it's in
the middle of a redesign which is a lot
to do at once so I'm on a lot of calls
with their marketing team kind of
figuring out the content strategy and
any revisions that have made to the
design and building templates for the
new system
okay the question was what books do I
recommend for learning web design or web
development okay um this is gonna be a
shameless plug it's not out yet but I'm
writing a textbook that's teaching
people how to get into HTML and CSS and
front-end development so hopefully
that'll be good when it comes out we by
Bloomsbury interactive publishing their
publisher in the UK I really like a
reilly books they can be kind of dry but
they explain the technical side of
things really well I like a lot of their
JavaScript book JavaScript the good
parts is when I remember really liking
it JavaScript patterns is really good
there just general JavaScript book
that's like this big it's huge but if
you have a specific question about
something like it's such an exhaustive
resource check-in overview and kind of
get a good explanation of specific
things I'm trying to think I can't
remember what it's called but there's
this company that makes a lot of
front-end development books and they
have they're kind of silly they have a
lot of cartoons in them so it's kind of
they try to make it humorous but it
makes it a little bit more interesting
to read a textbook I'll have to sit and
think about what they're called but
maybe if you google like funny web
design book it might pop up yeah and
then for design my favorite design books
have been focused mainly on UX research
and I just completely blanked on the
company name but they run a really big
UX consultancy group in a book apart a
book apart has a lot of different good
titles I don't know if you're familiar
with them but they run an event apart
and what's the website
yeah Jeffrey's Oldman help started that
website and they a lot of well-known
people will write just kind of a one-off
book on their specialties they have a
really good one on web typography which
is you know there's it's deceptively
simple but there's really a lot there
with web typography inside it setting
type for the web that was one of my
favorite books for sure I can't remember
his first name but is by something Brown
yeah and then online it's kind of
written in a textbook type format but
hack design is a really great free
course I don't know if you still can but
used to be able to sign up through email
and then they would send you a lesson a
week in your inbox and they have a lot
of different authors and it's more like
hack design how to learn design form
more of a technical background but yeah
they have a ton of different design
topics and then also coding for
designers so if you're more of a visual
learner anything that's aimed at
teaching like a designer how to code is
good because they try to make it yeah
more more visual
oh yeah that's a great question okay so
the question was since web technologies
are changing every year so rapidly where
do I see HTML CSS JavaScript going in
three to five years right or just in the
future for I mean this is a hard
question because I don't I think it's
kind of a maturity point to where we
aren't gonna see anything super crazy
changing I think hopefully CSS for
example will start getting better and
better like adding native support for
four variables and for more functional
programming type logic because that
makes it really easy to or easier to
write and maintain CSS in a way that's
maintainable and kind of follows best
coding practices hopefully HTML will
continue to go in more of a direction
for like they did with html5 or the tags
they added in the last version like more
native support for semantic elements I
think that's important for accessibility
is having a lot of those built in a lot
of ability to create more of a rich
expressive web it works better with SEO
the more a algorithm or something like
Google can understand the context of
your content based on the markup you're
using the better and smarter it can be
using it in different contexts yeah
okay so the question was how much coding
experience did I have before I got my
first job or my first project first
project okay um so my first project
real-world project was a non-profit in
Edmond called shepherds of love they
reached out to Francis Tuttle and wanted
a student to help them with their
website I had been in the program I
think maybe eight months at that point
and I had I knew a little bit about
WordPress I had built a couple you know
project websites in class I would say I
had like a decent understanding of HTML
and CSS I didn't really know any
JavaScript knew like a teeny tiny bit of
PHP maybe and I thought I knew a lot
more than I actually knew so I took on
this project agreed to develop a
wordpress site and I had to learn so
much for my first project I was woefully
unprepared but I think that's a really
good great way to learn is to take on
something real-- and then you find out
exactly what you need to know to build
that project so as long as you give
yourself time to learn I mean I think
it's hard to find unless you're doing
the same thing over and over again every
project your hat you have you're gonna
have to learn a new type of technology
or a new skill or what's changed since
the last time you used a technology so I
would say as long as you have some of
the basics down it's never too early to
take on a first project and and to yeah
just to tackle it because that's the
best way to learn
[Laughter]
sure yeah that's another great question
so the question was how do you know
what's a the right salary to ask for how
do you price yourself when you're
looking for a job and I think one of the
first things to do is do some research I
think salary comm or something like that
it's run by HR people and they post
salary ranges for different positions so
look at first of all the type of job
titles that you might be looking at and
then also what type of skills that you'd
be using in that position because
oftentimes job titles can vary so much
between different companies sometimes it
might be called something but it's a
better match to another job and then
they'll have a low end for that job in
your area and a high end and kind of a
median and I would shoot for somewhere
in the median if it's your first job you
don't want to undervalue yourself
especially when you accept a new
position because any future raises or
bonuses a lot of the times are based on
your base salary so if you're already
getting underpaid from the start then
you're hurting your growth potential for
the future because you're you know
you're inclined will be much slower if
your base starting salary is lower so
obviously you don't want to ask too much
and have them take you off the table so
asking like yeah salaries such as
sensitive people or sensitive thing for
people to talk about it can be hard to
ask people what they're making but if
you know someone he was comfortable
talking about what they make in the
field then you can kind of get a
baseline for what's realistic in the
area and then also looking at the type
of company so if you're trying to get a
job at a startup generally they don't
have as much revenue or ability to pay
you so it might be on the lower end of
that scale if it's at a bigger company
generally times they'll want to be come
hedid if so it would be towards the
median or maybe even the high end of the
scale so yeah and never agree to a
salary before you have an interview a
lot of people try to pin you down and
give try to get you to give a range
before you even get in the door and that
can kind of shoot your self in the foot
especially if the responsibilities are
going to be much higher than you
initially thought when we started
interviewing then they already have you
pegged a range that may not be a good
compensation for the type of work you
would be doing so
yeah research Glassdoor is another
really good place to research and see
what people the actual company get paid
at least if you can't find it for your
specific position then looking at market
pay for other positions in the company
and what they're paying compared to that
you can kind of get an idea of what
they're willing to pay for and then
always counteroffer it would be my other
piece of advice a lot of people are
scared especially in a first job to make
a counteroffer and just accept their
first salary but you know people they
expect you to bargain so the worst thing
that can happen is that they tell you no
and that's the easiest way to get a
higher salary to someone the start is
make a counteroffer maybe provide some
just justification for why you think you
deserve that higher number you could say
this is more in line with the market pay
for my position and based on the skills
that I have I think this is a fair
compensation for what you're looking for
and then just see what they come back
and the question was can I recommend any
JavaScript libraries like node angular
or react I would say anymore I'm not the
best person to ask that because most of
what I do isn't on the JavaScript side I
if I have to do anything in recent
projects it's mostly jQuery so I think
it highly depends on what you want to do
if you want to get into Web Apps and
certainly learning something like
angular react would be great if you're
looking more at web sites jQuery is
super common so no your use case for it
and then decide where to focus after
that there's no reason to learn all of
the frameworks just kind of decide what
you need to to get the job you want
that's a great question um so the
question was what do I like about or
what got me interested in web design and
development and what is it about the day
to day job that make me happy and so I
actually got started in web development
because I graduated from Oklahoma State
University in 2011 with a degree in
political science with an idea that I
was going to go to law school and I
started studying for the LSAT and then
thinking about whether I actually wanted
to be a lawyer and I just liked history
classes and studying law but I don't
think I actually wanted to be a lawyer
so after he graduated is like well crap
what do I do now and my brother is a web
developer and so he kept on telling me
that my type of people are in web
development and I'm still not quite sure
what that means but he he encouraged me
to like give it a shot he's like you
like computers and you like design so
maybe this could be like a really good
interaction of the two and my
sister-in-law had also graduated with a
degree in journalism and she was kind of
looking for something to try until she
would grayed out I'll long-term what she
wanted to do so she found Francis
Tuttle's program and enrolled in it and
I was like well why not why don't I
enroll in Francis Tuttle too and at the
very least I'll have my sister-in-law
there is a friend and so I joined the
program with her and she actually ended
up getting a job at an agency after six
months and left the program and I stayed
in a little bit longer and ended up
finishing the program because I was
scared to get a job but yeah I just I
found that yeah I was always interested
in computer science but I thought it
wouldn't be interesting enough for some
reason but I think I just don't have an
real understanding of what you could do
with it and what it actually was and so
the more I got into web development and
especially design I'm in all of my jobs
I've done a good amount of development
combined with the design so I like that
it has kind of that nerdy technical
aspect of I love researching things so
I'm always getting to research too
oh geez and to learn I really enjoy
coding so I get to code everyday and
there's not many jobs that I can think
of that I can design something and use a
creative side and then combine that with
something that's highly technical as
well so it kind of plays into two things
I really really enjoy I love the
flexibility of being in web development
I've met a lot of really great people so
I think meeting fun people and then just
really enjoying the day-to-day work keep
me happy in my job
okay so the question was would I take a
language based class like C++ or Java or
die just nix it and learn it myself I
think that depends a lot on the class
itself because a lot of them are kind of
out to date at universities most people
I've heard if taken a coding class in
college they only have like one lab a
week and so I think having so little
hands-on learning combined with so much
Theory learning like it if you want to
learn the theory behind it and that
could probably be a really great fit but
if you want to get more of the hands-on
learning how to code then I would maybe
go a different route because yeah it's
really hard to learn something if you're
I mean unless you want to put in a lot
of time outside of class and maybe that
would be a good balance of learning the
theory and being able to learn the
actual coding side as well but from my
personal opinion I think for formal
education something like a vocational
school for languages is one of the best
ways to learn because it was it was the
theory side but it was also we coded for
like six hours a day so I think that's
the best way to learn is to learn by
doing
sure that's a great question when so
recently I've been on non-coding or web
development podcasts because that's kind
of my way to relax and shut it off but
when I do listen to web podcasts I like
the next web gen Myer I think is who
creates that and then I can't I camera
what it's called but has Chris coiour
and a developer from Austin and they had
a podcast show that is really really
funny and so if you want to listen to
something I recommend that one very
highly cuz it's entertaining but yeah in
terms of podcasts I mostly use those for
more like entertainment type and less
learning
I do like newsletters for keeping up to
date because anything that creates less
work for me and being more efficient is
great so someone else does all the hard
work and tries to find things that
people are talking about and send it
directly to your email so you can kind
of scan through and see what are people
talking about kind of the trends between
the the different newsletters and decide
what do I need to spend my time learning
to keep up to date see what's happening
so I think that's a great way for sure
okay so the question was our coding cam
coding boot camps considered worthwhile
and what was the second part of the
question and are they competitive are
the skills competitive um I can't speak
a lot about boot camps but from what
I've seen it does seem like a lot of
them give a good variety of skills that
are in demand for the workplace I mean
at the end of the day their business is
so if they can't get their participants
jobs then they're not going to stay in
business so from what I seen it does
seem like they stay pretty up-to-date
and from what I've heard from other
people a lot of what they get out of
boot camps is they want to you have a
certain success rate of people placed in
jobs so it can be a great opportunity to
maybe have a job opportunity that you
might not either have through the
connections that you can make but like
with anything there's going to be
varying quality levels and what you get
so but what I I would say though that I
think most of what they teach you could
teach yourself through online resources
for probably much much cheaper but it
depends on your learning style and some
people aren't they struggle with
self-direction and kind of deciding what
to focus on so if you want someone to
kind of do all that for you
and an easy-to-follow formula then then
sure I think a boot camp would be good
to start learning
Oh from you're forgetting a okay so the
question is how do you get a freelance
job when it seems like HTML CSS and
JavaScript aren't enough in your
perspective to get a freelance job I
would say um yeah it depends on
obviously where the the source is coming
from so if you're contracting with a
company who already has a development
team they would probably be a lot
stricter on what they want because they
want someone who can who can work in
kind of their team environment and up to
their team standards from an external
basis a client that this might sound
horrible but someone who's less
tech-savvy is not gonna really know
whether or not you're up-to-date with
JavaScript for example or how good your
coding skills are so it's not to say
that you should screw them over and do a
bad job but there's more of an
opportunity to take on something and
learn while you're doing it so as long
as you follow through on your promises
and you're ending up with a good quality
product and then there's nothing wrong
with with learning while on the job as
long as you're not misrepresenting
anything to the client or trying to be
dishonest so maybe try try freelance
jobs and a different environment so
rather than at a company or an agency
you look for individuals or smaller
businesses or something like that